I don't want to do it dude I don't want
to do it okay are you ready okay you do
it
give me a countdown I will I promise
so lately the found-footage genre is
getting a little bit tedious there's
been some really bad ones there's been
some good ones for me my favorite has
always been Cloverfield I mean some
people badmouth the film but I always
really liked that movie Chronicle is
very similar to Cloverfield and then it
takes that found footage style but it
uses a big special effects track
Stravaganza and an interesting story to
be able to create a realistic situation
that we can get invested in emotionally
but also have an extremely good time
watching gonna get become Chronicle is
one of those surprises that can really
only happen a few times a year it's one
of those movies where you see the
trailer for you like huh that's
interesting that could be awful that
really could be awful or it could be a
huge surprise which Chronicle is I love
this movie Chronicle is awesome
the plot is very similar but this movie
really is about the plot its move about
the execution it's about this
interesting situation that is just you
know out-of-this-world crazy and
unbelievable but the way it's shown the
way it's filmed the way they they handle
the found footage idea makes it seem so
real
how is this guy's problem
we need to do that see for me where the
problem I've always had on the
found-footage genre is that after a
while you're like no one will be filming
this anymore everyone wouldn't put their
cameras down and run away see this movie
takes it in a really interesting
approach though because from right from
the start of this movie before these
teenagers discover this thing that they
touch underground that gives them these
abilities it shows the main kid this
movie the kid who's tormented he has an
abusive father his mother is sick
everyone treats him bad at school but it
shows him from the very first shot he
gets a camera it sets up that he is
going to try to document all these
things that are happening to him in the
movie he kind of explains it as a
barrier between himself and others
because he just wants to be introverted
from society was it an accident Andrew
Andrew worry about Andrew listen to me
we can't screw around with this it's too
dangerous
another really cool thing that the
director did this movie and perhaps my
favorite trick he does he's able to
transcend that whole found-footage thing
you know just the cameras gonna be from
one angle and we're gonna talk or it's
gonna fall down and they're gonna see
stuff or it's gonna be shaky what he
does is he has the main kid become
really interested in moving the camera
with this telekinesis and having the
camera follow him places and so you're
able to get these really amazing shots
as some of these kids are doing things
with the camera they're also using their
powers to float the camera around and
everything so we look at these really
awesome and inventive shots hey drew
it's good game stop
this right now I'm talking a lot about
the technical aspects of this movie but
emotionally it's extremely resonating
for such a short film I was amazed at
how much emotion and depth these
characters had with such limited
knowledge about them and the main person
is this kid this tormented kid he's
abused his mom is sick everyone greets
him bad at school and you're like dude
just you know he's gonna freak out use
his powers and when he does it is some
of the coolest special effects sequences
I have seen in a while the last 20
minutes of this movie are absolutely
fantastic
I loved Chronicle the Great Famine may
continue to be on my best of the year
list for a while I'm gonna give it an A
- making it says what is that I do we
once actor Steve wait up man look at
this oh so I like to know what's your
favorite found footage film let me know
in the comments below if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes